I did a um an animated video which is on
YouTube called The Changing World Order
and it's an animated entertaining video
that's about 40 minutes long and it'll
tell you the whole thing better than I
can squeeze in now but let me tell you
okay what's an order okay
um an order is the system that's
operating how do you operate so for
example
um there is a domestic order we have a
constitution and democracy and that's a
system that operates and that continues
on until there's a war and then there's
another system that comes and replaces
our system has lasted for a long time
there's also a world order in other
words a world system and that world
system of operating comes after a war
why does a war happen because
conflicting parties of about equal power
have a fight and the dominant power wins
and then they get to set the rules and
the last time that happened was in 1945
alive because of the end of World War II
so you know at the end of World War II
the United States had 80 percent of the
world's money gold was money then it had
half the world's economy it had a
dominant military power and uh for that
reason because it was the dominant power
on the in the uh new New York is where
the United Nations is
um Washington DC is where the IMF and
World Bank they put it there because
that it was the American World Order the
dollar was the world's Reserve currency
and that always happens you if that
there was the TR before that and at the
end of world war one there was the
Treaty of Versailles and the winners of
the Treaty of the Versailles determine
how the system was going to work after
that and if you go back in history
repeatedly there is always a world order
there's always happens this way and it
continues